not a Border Town we don't have an
infrastructure to handle this this type
of a level of immigration to our city we
don't have the ability we're not Texas
yeah you are now though is the thing
well we're not a Border Town yet now you
are but we don't have the infrastructure
better build up it's this is not like
it's a new problem the illegal
immigration problem's been going on for
50 years since the Democrats started it
so yeah it now you should have probably
started to build that infrastructure a
little earlier you just thought you'd
never have to deal with the consequences
of your own actions but now you do
so you are you are a Border Town good
I'm glad she says she's going to build
the infrastructure I'm glad she says
she's going to ramp up the resources I'm
glad she says she's going to welcome
these people with open arms great
wonderful I mean obviously federal law
enforcement should Deport the illegal
aliens
but okay you're at the level of the
mayor you're going to welcome these
people that's great one thing she said
that's not true she said we're not a
Border Town yes you are now you are